A startup of the year, in order to be a great startup, to be a great entrepreneur,...
...you've got to be in this 25/7.
That you're on this, this is your full-time passion and your love.
This isn't, "Well, I'm working at Google and on the side I've got this little project."
Or, "I'm at an ad agency but I'm dabbling in this."
This is you know, you'd sell your mother for a shot at this.
Not, I don't mean this, it's "Startup of the Year."
I would think that would be the other thing,...
...that "Startup of the Year" wouldn't be considered a win to this person.
That's like nice, but the win to this person is this company.
And that there's just no other distraction from this company...
...kind of has to make and then not do anything.